foreign
North Carolina and talk to Gabriel
what's up Gabriel
yes hey how are you hi yes good great
grand wonderful how are you
doing pretty well excellent what's up
so
uh
um it might get a little bit emotional
it's all good man
I would like to know how
the best way is to go about maintaining
a relationship with my sister
um when she is currently in a romantic
relationship with a 50-something year
old man who I believe possibly groomed
her
um she's just turned 18 in March oh jeez
whoa
yeah
so
um
we this had been going on I personally
knew the man before she did
um and so she
had met him and would see him on a
weekly basis out at a like a social
setting a social function and um
just over time started having like this
little crush on him and then it started
developing into more
um and
there were measures put up to where they
wouldn't have any more contact in like
the social setting was
um done away with so that way they
wouldn't be seeing each other anymore
um and she had told everybody in the
family that she wasn't seeing him
anymore
that there was no conversation anymore
that there was no
um seeing him at all but things got kind
of funny back in I want to say September
and we thought that there's possibility
that she was definitely seeing him and
talking to him so I actually had a very
upfront conversation with her about what
this would look like for her life what
it would look like
um like all the different possibilities
and I also was very clear about how it
would change our relationship
um
and then I called him
and I asked him directly you know are
you having any relations with her right
now are you talking to her currently she
has plans to come and move in with you
do you know anything about this
and he said no he knew nothing that
there was no contact they weren't
talking but some of the things that he
was saying led me to believe that they
definitely were talking
um
so yeah some time passed and went on
my mother and stepfather ended up
involving the police but the police said
that legal age was 16 so there was
nothing that they could do either
freaking North Carolina dude
so unbelievable
if you are a legislator in the state of
North Carolina you should be ashamed
with yourself you shouldn't be able to
sleep
right it's just disgusting
50 years old
with a 16 year old
yeah
so um God Almighty what the what the
hell is happening to our country man
I don't know God it's so disgusting it's
just disgusting
oh my God I urged her to
um hey here here's the thing you're not
there is no conversation you can have
with her
she is a child under the spell of an
adult that's why they need adults in
their lives to protect them from
predators like this man
there's not a conversation you haven't
had with her that where she would go oh
okay I get it now that's not gonna
happen
she is living in an altered reality
which is why
a consent age of 16.
is so insane
God leave him
so I'll tell you this I'm proud of you
for calling him Direct
I'm proud for your mother and stepfather
call the police
as you were talking I kept saying hey
there's gonna be phone records there's
going to be
all the photos she sent him that he
requested from her it's gonna be all
that crap is going to be out there and
discoverable because it's electronic but
I forgot you're in North Carolina so
disgusting
here's oh super helpless yeah I I wish I
had another I wish I had I wish I had
something else I could tell you
I feel helpless for you
so I'm gonna tell you something that
nobody else is going to tell you okay
and that is
the great Evander Holyfield
versus Mike Tyson move
okay
here's what the move was
everybody was terrified of Mike Tyson he
would beat people before they even got
in the ring
and he had an uppercut that came from
the floor would knock your head to the
Moon
and he had a very particular way he
moved his right foot when he was
engaging in this uppercut
and what happened was everybody when
they felt his body shifting they would
back up a few inches
which gave them gave him the exact space
he needed to land that crushing blow
and then he fought Evander Holyfield who
talks about how he trained for months
that every time his body Mike Tyson's
body went to to make that maneuver he
stepped in and got really close
which made that punch impossible to land
and over time he wore Mike Tyson out and
defeated the undefeatable
and so here's what I want to tell you
every time you get at arm's link from
her
that's when you're gonna get hurt
and that's when she's gonna get hurt
so I'm gonna tell you to do something
crazy I want you to lean in and get real
close
would she go to a weekly breakfast with
you or a weekly lunch with just YouTube
just to talk about sister stuff
um
I mean it might be
over the phone but we're currently
living about five hours apart okay
I'd set that up
I'd set up a weekly letter with her
so that she gets something in the mail
from you every week
and here's what we're doing
We are Never Gonna Let Her completely
detach from reality
one day she's going to open her eyes and
go oh god what have I done
and we want to give her a trail of bread
come crumbs back to you
and that she will immediately turn
scared and look to her left and you will
have been standing there the whole time
and most advice what you're going to get
is we'll just cut her off forget about
her
she'll come crawl him back and I think
that that's that kind of wisdom has
given us the the world that we inhabit
now I think it's wrong
and so I would love for you to say hey
you're my sister I wanna we're gonna
talk every week and put a Time on the
calendar that you don't ever Miss
and you might get off the phone
Gabrielle and just cry
yeah
to keep showing up for her
and keep showing up for her
and there may be moments when you have
to put boundaries in like hey I want you
to come visit and you can say Hey you
know I really don't like I really
I don't want to be around him
I'd love to hang out with you I'd love
it love it love it but you know how I
feel about him so I'm asking you respect
my boundaries and she's 18 so she'll
probably say something like if you don't
love him then you don't love me and you
can say you know that's dumb you know
it's not true
yeah right so there will be those
moments and you know those will come
can I ask you a hard question
yeah of course was there anything in
your y'all's ecosystem growing up that
like
it's just not super common
what was that what was the the
breadcrumb trail that led her to this
guy
um she really wanted out of a house
that my parents had divorced and she was
the only sister like the only girl left
at home
um
with three brothers
and
um was there abuse
my mom and stepdad don't have the best
relationship there's constant fighting
constant the house is constantly loud
and doesn't feel very stable
and that's just what you've heard you
don't even know exactly right
right
I mean there were ample opportunities
like we my husband and I
made it very clear that she could come
and live with us she had
um another sister who offered the same
thing that she could come and move in
and
I think it's just she waited too long
and then this looked like a really good
option and it's super hard now to have
like to continue a relationship because
I've got a five-month-old daughter and
under no circumstances do I want him
around her
it's really hard to see like if he was
pedophile who groomed her or if he was
an older man and it was like
it sounds so crazy but like right time
right circumstances even though it's so
wrong does that even make sense yeah I
was I'm always going to put that
lay that burden
um in the hands of the 50 year old
yeah all right
yeah and so I'm I mean if you're dancing
on that line it's just you yeah
you got issues as is the man's
disgusting there's just not a way around
it and the police have said dude there's
nothing we can do
so I think any any effort you spend
trying to dig into that at this point
after the police have been involved and
they've wiped their hands clean I don't
know there's a lot more to do
yeah maybe you could dig around and see
if you could find out they were
contacting each other when she was only
15 instead of 16 but I mean
maybe but right now he's playing the
letter of the law
right
I think and they did that very well yeah
I I think the
um I think the energy best spent is
creating a new relationship with her
that is distant enough from this guy
that she never loses touch with the fact
that her family loves her
and there may have been so much chaos
growing up that she just can't see the
forest from the trees she can't feel it
or see it
okay
but you can break through that and and
and invite her back into your life not
him
but her right and this doesn't mean you
give her money
and this doesn't mean you fill in the
blank pay a rent this doesn't mean all
that kind of stuff
right that means I'm we're talking every
week and if she wants to come down and
see her niece oh that'd be awesome
yeah
he can't come he's not welcome
so maybe the conversation with you and
your husband is setting up boundaries
for
um what is this relationship going to
look like with her
and again don't chase it to where you
get so close you fall over the edge too
but I want you to think of ways you can
lean in and get closer to your sister
not in a manipulative way but just in a
way that when she turns her head and
opens her eyes and goes oh no
everything that I'm involved in right
now is wrong
and I thought this was the only ticket
out of a house of chaos and abuse and I
was wrong
and you're right there and you have been
the whole way
and for everybody listening out there if
you've got somebody in your life who you
love and you care about making dumb
decisions
find ways you can re-engage the
relationship not not in
not
um don't give a drunk a drink or all
that kind of you know all that stuff
find a way you can reconnect
healing changing Behavior changing life
always comes through reconnection
always